[Music]
after seven decades of communist rule
China has become one of the world's
great powers this video we look back at
the nine moments that have defined the
People's Republic of China on October
the 1st 1949 Mao Zedong became the
founding of the People's Republic of
China in Tiananmen Square here in
Beijing was the first time in nearly a
century that China had been unified this
time under the revolutions leader and as
every school kid here learns there's no
new China without the Communist Party
[Applause]
the Communist Party quickly made social
and economic reforms at the same time as
purging rivals and class enemies
whichever male grew frustrated with pace
of change so launched the Great Leap
Forward in 1958 this is a plan to
collectivized agriculture and also
industrialized China basically overnight
it was a complete disaster led to a
famine that killed tens of millions of
people
after Great Leap Forward malposition was
greatly weakened the Cultural Revolution
was how he tried to reclaim it he
incited people especially young students
to denounce bourgeois and imperialist
elements still present in Chinese
society it was an ideological frenzy a
bloodbath a self-imposed civil war which
may have killed around a million to two
million people Mao's death unleashed a
factional battle for succession through
a series of coos and tasks arrest of
dong Xiao ping himself and old
revolutionary ended up in power with Mal
gone the great Hausman dead china can
choose a different part
daang reformed the Chinese clothing he
abandoned the radical socialist economic
model embraced many aspects of
capitalism instead or as it was called
socialism with Chinese characteristics
farmers were allowed to cultivate their
own plots of land and preneur allowed to
stock businesses foreigners were allowed
to invest as the economy became more
free so too did the political atmosphere
new ideas spread across China the
protests became more common perhaps even
tolerated by the authorities reached
ahead in 1989 when pro-democracy
protests happen all across the country
but most famously in Tiananmen Square
the same place Mao Saddam had proclaimed
the People's Republic of China
after weeks of protest on June 4 tanks
and troops moved in slaughtering
hundreds if not thousands of protesters
it was proof of the Communist Party's
determination to hold on to power no
matter what the cost
the Tiananmen Massacre led to China
being isolated internationally but not
for long
it was reintegrated culminating in its
accession in 2001 to the World Trade
Organization that meant terrace for his
exports were much reduced and that led
to a huge economic boom that's continued
to this day at the expense some would
argue of jobs in the US and in Europe
[Music]
the Beijing Olympics in 2008 where
China's coming-out party a show of
self-confidence and regain status they
also coincided with a global financial
crisis a crisis which left many here
wondering about the self-proclaimed
superiority of Western capitalism the
West was on the way down
China was on the way up in 2012 Xi
Jinping became general secretary of the
Chinese Communist Party he later became
president the People's Republic of China
since then he's proved the most powerful
leader since Mao himself he's had a much
more assertive foreign policy stamped
down on internal dissent and he's
realized communist ideology the 2018 he
abolished presidential term limits
meaning he could be around for a long
time yet
[Music]